MARK MIRCHANDANI: Google
Cloud makes it easy for teams
to get the cloud resources
they need to build and host
applications, but there are
so many tools and services
that controlling costs and
managing your organization
can get tricky if
not set up properly.
Don't worry.
We're here to help.
"Beyond Your Bill" is a
video series dedicated
to helping you better
understand what
you're spending on the
cloud and best practices
for managing your
cloud environment.
On this episode,
we'll take a look
at how to organize
your GCP resources.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Questions about
resource management
are top of mind for
many GCP administrators.
In fact, the most common Google
Cloud billing support requests
focus on access
issues and confusion
around tracking
payment for services.
To help you avoid having
these same issues,
we'll go over some
best practices
and answer some common
questions such as,
how should I
structure my resources
for effective cost management,
and what's the ideal folder
structure for my organization?
First, let's start with
what we mean by a resource,
and then we'll cover how to best
organize them and grant access.
Resources are defined as
any Google Cloud Platform
service such as Compute
Engine and BigQuery,
and they can exist
in a hierarchy.
When we say resource hierarchy,
we're referring to the way
that you can organize your
Google Cloud environment
and how that maps to your
organization's structure,
letting you manage access
and permission for groups
of related resources.
As you plan and set up
your resource hierarchy,
make sure to consider
the requirements
for your organization.
You can always change the
structure in the GCP console,
so start with the simplest
structure that meets your needs
and make changes as required.
Here's a diagram of what the
different parts of the resource
hierarchy look like.
Let's start from the top
and work our way down.
Everything you'll
manage in Google Cloud
is under your domain
and organization.
They're kind of
like an umbrella.
If you're an individual user
with a G Suite or a Cloud
Identity account, you may
not have an organization,
which means that some features
won't be available to you
until you create one.
If you're getting started
with an organization,
or if you're migrating existing
projects to a new organization,
the organization setup wizard
may be a good place to begin.
The wizard guides you through
recommendations and steps
for setting up
everything, so check out
the link for more information.
The domain is handled through
G Suite or Cloud Identity
and helps you manage
user profiles,
while the organization is
managed through the GCP console
and lets you manage GCP
resources and access.
With an organization,
projects belong to the org
rather than to the
user that created them.
Org admins can see and
manage all projects
as well as set up
permissions and policies
that'll be inherited for
different groups of resources.
This is especially helpful when
a team member creates a project
and then later
leaves the company.
Each organization and domain
have separate permission
settings.
Make sure to set up multiple
admins or use a group for each
to ensure a reasonable
level of redundancy.
Billing accounts are under
the organization and track
any charges for
associated projects.
A billing account
has its own roles
and permissions so
you can manage users
for billing related functions.
Billing account users
can associate projects
and see spend, while billing
account admins can additionally
unlink projects, enable billing
export, and set budgets.
In addition, only
billing account admins
can contact billing
support, so make
sure to have more than
one admin or use a group
and ensure your team
knows who they are.
We recommend sticking
to a single billing
account per organization
and making sure
only your admins can create
new billing accounts.
You can do that by removing
the billing account creator
role from your organization.
In most cases, you'll only
need one billing account,
and creating
multiple can make it
tricky to track down payments.
If you need to deal
with multiple currencies
or follow certain
legal requirements,
you may have to create
multiple billing accounts,
but don't forget to still have
redundancy for your admins.
When setting up a
billing account,
the admins should
enable BigQuery export
as soon as possible since the
export data isn't retroactive.
This way, your usage data
will be tracked and ready
for analysis using
a variety of tools.
We'll talk more about
exporting and analyzing
billing data in later videos.
The payments profile is
a Google level resource
that sits outside
of Google Cloud
and is used for paying
for all Google services,
such as Google Ads
or Chrome licenses.
It's possible to have the
same admins for your billing
account and your
payment profile,
but make sure that you still
set up multiple administrators
or use groups.
In the payment profile
settings, review the preferences
for notifications and
statements as well as
ensuring that you
have invoice delivery
set up for email
and paper invoices.
Having multiple admins, payment
methods, and notification
methods will make sure that you
get the right information when
you need it and avoid
any potential issues.
Projects are used for
grouping any resources
like Google Kubernetes
Engine or Cloud Storage.
A project can exist
under a folder,
so it can be grouped logically
to match your company's
structure as well as inherit
any permissions from folders
above it or from the
organization at the top.
Projects can also
have labels across
your entire organization, which
you can use to horizontally
group projects and services.
Folders and projects
can have permissions
that let you control who can
create, edit, or just view
resources inside of them.
For example, you could
set up certain users
as project creators
so that they can
create new projects,
or just project viewers
so that they can see
what's being used
and view the costs for
an individual project.
The permissions and structure
are flexible and changeable,
so you can organize your
hierarchy to meet your needs.
Here's an example of matching
an organization's structure.
In this image, the
first level of folders
represents departments, the next
level teams, and then products
with labels for environments
like production.
Another example might
be using folders
for environments and
labels for teams,
or folders for lines of business
and labels for applications.
A project can have
multiple labels,
but it can only directly
exist under a single folder.
For projects,
labels, and folders,
ensure that you use
naming conventions
that are familiar to your team.
These names are referenced in
the console, billing reports,
and for resource organization.
It's imperative that clear
and well-understood naming is
used across your organization.
Of course, the specifics
will depend on your team
and your governance.
Ultimately, the structure
and naming convention
are meant to follow whatever
works best for your org.
Taking the time upfront to
plan your resource structure
for what's right
for your business
can save you a lot of confusion
and hassle down the road.
With that overview of
the resource hierarchy,
the next step is to talk
more about billing accounts
and the payments profile.
I definitely
recommend checking out
the links for a deeper dive
and for more best practices
around resource organization.
In the next video, we'll
set up a billing account,
go over permissions, and
discuss more best practices.
[MUSIC PLAYING]